Parks and Rec
confirming what
that's not possible
oh no
hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since I became your
assistant that's because every time
someone calls and requests a meeting
with you I always schedule it for March
31st why because I didn't think March
31st existed
30 days has September April March and
November June and November
today is March 31st I know how we doing
pretty good I may have promised a new
Aquatic Center to somebody is that a
problem I diagnosed two melanomas
they're both benign how many more
meetings 20
April was supposed to be the moat that
kept the citizen barbarians away from
Swanson Castle instead she blew up the
castle and stabbed me in the face
I hired you to do one thing
just one
I don't care that you text all day and
sleep at your desk in fact I encourage
it but only because you were doing that
one thing
keeping this crap off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
God I know
hey sorry dude I don't need your
sympathy
or yours I wasn't offering my sympathy
well hello there you must be Ron Swanson
oh welcome to Casa Ludgate hello Mr
ludgers ah call me Larry Larry
it's zuzu's boss oh Ron Rita Ludgate oh
you have no idea how nice it is to meet
you
oh come in for God's sake what can I get
you to drink oh could you take your
shoes off please thank you so much
uh nothing to drink thanks oh okay is
April around uh Zuzu you have a guest
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
I want you to come back well I don't
want to come back
the end
I was talking to Andy about you and he
made me realize that I need you back at
work what did he say don't recall fine
I'll come back
good
okay I'm leaving
bye Zuzu
bye Duke Silber
my mom has all your albums
I recognized you the day we met
have you told anyone no
no girl
no Henry stop it okay Henry cute kid
Andy
you got a sec yeah Henry
why are you working the permits desk and
why was that child clubbing your nuggets
I'm trying to stop April from taking a
job with Chris so I'm doing everything
she hates doing for the next month
that's going to work she said it might
but it's all I got man
give me the list
I'll help you
oh my God thank you
you got it no I don't care about their
relationship I just don't want to lose
April
I would never be able to find a worse
assistant
do you fish April no fish are gross let
me give you a piece of fishing advice I
said I don't when you have a fish on the
line you don't just drag it behind the
boat
you either reel it in or you cut them
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about Maybe not
maybe you really do hate Andy maybe
moving to Indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know
[Music]
I swear it's almost like they don't want
you to win
well you better practice you gotta win
me a teddy bear I'm gonna win you a
million teddy bears well I want a
billion teddy bears well that's a little
unrealistic
it's a hard game
2 million
deal
[Applause]
hey I love you
dude shut up that is awesome sauce
they're missing this long they're
usually dead well if that's true then
you're gonna have to answer to the whole
town and God okay you were the one who
let him out Tom okay now stop trying to
blame me Jerry can you please be quiet I
can't hear myself not talking to Andy
Ron will you please tell me why April is
mad at me Ron can you please tell all of
you be quiet Andy she's mad because you
said awesome sauce instead of I love you
too April he loves you stop being a
child Tom you're clearly at fault here
blaming Jerry won't save you Jerry we
both know you were shotgunning funnel
cakes instead of watching little
Sebastian so everyone apologized to
everyone else
sorry
I do love you
you do
yeah
yeah that's what you know makes the
sauce so awesome
oh Jay just farted I'm very upset I get
nervous
I know you normally hate foundations but
this one I think you'll actually like we
take people that don't know what they
want to do and then put them to work
doing cool stuff all over the world
and I start in a couple months well I
had hoped you'd choose a more dignified
trade like masonry or logging but you
are out of local government and that's a
step in the right direction it's
definitely the job I wanted
but it means that we have to move to
Washington
well
then bully for you
if you intend to move I suppose you
should return the spare key to my house
the one I gave you years ago when you
were my assistant for emergencies
okay
good talk
hi Andy I hate people but you are okay
it's weird woof woof April oh my God
baby we're so into me that's hilarious
that's it it's a dead end no more clues
see me in my office
if it makes you feel any better I had a
big crush on you too
it does make me feel a little better
thanks
God
get off my boat
so I guess we are celebrating that
you trusted me and I let you down
great I changed my house locks every 16
days that key has been useless since the
second Tuesday after I gave it to you
what matters is that I trust you and
admire you as a person
I will be sorry to see you leave this
town for many reasons
not the least of which is that you
created a puzzle that even I couldn't
solve
and boy oh boy did you love Andy
woof woof
all right